Beloved class of 2021,
I stand here in
awe of you.
Right now,
this celebration is what
Benedictine nun and spiritual
writer Joan Chittister would
call a "firework moment".
Your accomplishments
both within and outside of your
fields of study, extend far
beyond formal measure.
There were likely times leading
up to this day when you felt
broken or without hope.
There might have been times
when you could not imagine how
to find your way through
to the end.
And yet here you are,
a fuller and deeper you.
Although this day is not what
any of us thought it would be
when you began this journey,
even if bittersweet in part,
it is a day to be cherished.
You are to be cherished.
In the uncertainty, in the
hard work, in the
failures and in the thriving,
you have persisted through
it all, and today you must
allow yourself
to simply sparkle.
And now, my beloved Yale family,
wherever you might be, I invite
you to join me
in the spirit of prayer,
Almighty and Loving Creator,
You are the Force that lights
the stars. The Architect of
every cell, the Source
of all Truth.
We look to you
as many expressions of one
living mystery, a mystery
beyond all telling.
In this moment, we are people
grieving many different types
of losses, and our hearts beat
with the rhythm of lament as we
cope with emotions too
complex for any of us
to fully understand.
We who share this beautiful but
aching world, we who look at the
same sun and the same
moon are of people called
to communal restoration.
As students of your handiwork,
we gathered at Yale from
throughout the Earth with
exquisite ambitions and have
been blessed at this place of
light and truth with the
freedom to let them grow.
Our God of all generations.
You are the guardian of where
we are going and who
we are becoming.
We are filled with gratitude
for our families, friends,
teachers and guides.
Their arms have sheltered us,
their shoulders have
boosted us, and today their
hearts are holding fast to us.
Bless us as we seek to
reimagine a world made better
by the considerable gifts we
will now bring to it.
May we exude an intelligence
that is inspired by justice,
guided by tenderness,
moved by holiness,
and always informed by love.
As we greet tomorrow, steady us
on solid ground and together
may we become vibrant living
examples of shalom, of salaam,
of shanti, of peace.
Let us say Amen.